okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p our
voicemail line is made possible by our
good friends over at linguist linguist
has built a really effective spaced
repetition based language learning app
which is powered by AI i've been using
it to improve my French my French has
always been come see come saw I think is
the right way I would say it and I'm
going to need to avail myself of my
French skills soon for a work related
project that's bringing me back to
France so I've been using linguist to
refresh and improve my French and it's
been very very helpful I love it and I
encourage you to try it for free no
credit card required at Ling viscom
slash Pakman that linguist with a V dot
comm slash Pakman here is today's
voicemail which is really strange I
don't know what I might have said that
would have triggered a voicemail like
this but a very nice sounding woman
called in with an extraordinarily
specific turkey burger recipe which I
don't think is a phrase that's ever been
said on the program turkey burger but in
any case let's listen okay but my name
is Trish I was just calling because I
was wondering do you love turkey burgers
but you never quite sure how to make
them well now I can tell you how to do
it it's easy
first just top the burger with one slice
of cheese and heat it until the cheese
melts I'm assuming you've already made
the turkey burger part then what you're
gonna want to do is spread some
mayonnaise uncut spies and rolls or you
could just use regular bread make sure
you layer the bottom bread or half of
the roll with a half a cup of lettuce
one sliced tomato and one slice of red
onion then you're going to top it with
the burger also you could add two slices
of avocado and two pieces of turkey
bacon if you want to make it really
exciting and enjoy it anyway last step
you're going to want to cover all of
those ingredients with the top of the
roll or other slice of bread anyway make
sure you serve it immediately and enjoy
bye I don't know
what to make of this it actually sounds
like a really good turkey burger the
only addition I might make of some
grilled jalapenos I think would go
really well with that the avocado slices
and the turkey bacon but can you think
of anything Pat that would have
triggered someone to call in and it by
the way I love the kids yelling in the
background - it just it's also
atmospheric and and lovely I can't think
of any reason why someone would call
this show and leave that recipe although
I've made very specific notes and
planned to make that tonight for dinner
well Trish started the voicemail by
saying that she just had this on her
mind that she was just wondering so I
don't think that you suggested anything
that would make it seem like you needed
its turkey burger recipe but I feel like
assembling the burger is the easy part
like the actual preparing the meat would
be the difficult part but hey I'm a
vegan I'm out of my element here
yes she's skipping the most important
part that can make it really good which
is what are you making the burger the
patty itself from are you using a
combination of light meat and dark meat
ground turkey are you mixing in any
little bits of onion are you what what
else are you doing are you making it
more like a meatball including a little
bit of breadcrumbs and an egg although I
think quite frankly that might make it a
little heavy to then put between two
pieces of bread with avocado and
mayonnaise I think that that that may be
a little much but in any case love the
recipe I guess use the voicemail line to
leave me interesting recipes and I will
put a picture up on Instagram if I end
up making this over the weekend on
today's bonus show we will talk about
mayor Pete Budaj edge and some of the
articles that are being written about
him and his campaign and more I think
people will find it interesting we will
also on today's bonus show talk about
how six states plus Washington DC are
suing over changes to school lunch rules
what are those changes I will tell you
and lastly murder charges have been
dropped against the Vietnamese woman
allegedly involved in the death of Kim
Jong Un's half-brother that's a story
we've actually been covering for you
like it's been going on for for a couple
years at this point if not longer time
flies but it's not a new story and
charges have now been dropped where do
you get to listen to
were watched these stories that I'm
talking about the answer is the bonus
show become a member at WWJ in pokémon
calm or become a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show either platform
will give you instant access to the
bonus show and a bunch of other great
perks the party doesn't have to end
right now I'm going to quickly grill up
a turkey burger and then I will be back
to host the bonus show momentarily